[拍手]
こんにちは
佐々木宏と申します
私は今秋田県内で外国人観光客を地方都市に誘客する
そんな仕事をしています
そんな中で今日は
実際に秋田に外国人が来るということ
そしてそれが
この地方都市においてどんな意味があるのか
その現状をお話ししたいなと思います
外国人が
地方都市に入る本当のイン
まず最初に皆さんこの数字をご覧下さい
この数字皆さん何だかわかるでしょうか
これは
2040年までにこの日本全国から
なくなるかもしれない市町村の数を表しています
896ですとてつもない数字です
理由は何か
世界最速で進む高齢化と人口減少です
私自身観光業を通してこの
地域における環境がどんどん悪くなっていく
そんな姿を目の当たりにしてきました
私は公共高校を卒業してすぐにホテル前になりました
最初は長野県の蓼科というところで
その次に東京の的真ん中のホテルで働きました
たまたまですが
地方と都会のホテル両方で働いたことによって違いが鮮明になりました
一番の違いは何かそれは外国人の数です
その当時から
唱えにいる外国人お客様はおそらく
お客様の半分くらいすでに外国人でした
片一方長野県の剛士だという場所で外国人の観光客を見ることはほとんどありません
でした
東京に振る海外のお客様とても特徴的です
私が働いてたホテルでは多くの方はビジネスマンでした
なので何度も一人でグループで日本を訪れてビジネスをされる
東京大阪京都この辺はビジネスでいきます
北海道九州有名な観光地は絶対に行きます
そんなお客様が私には回ベルマンに何を聞いてくるかといえば
とても面白い質問でした
例えば
よろしい
なぜ日本人は名刺をこんなに丁寧に渡すんだとか
日本人は電話をしているとき誰も前目の前になりにお辞儀をするよねーの
あれはどこで学んだと小学校から学ぶのか
みたいな
そういったことを聞いてくるんですね彼ら何が知りたいか
観光地じゃないんです日本人の行動
分かそこに対してもっと深く知っていきたいとそういった要望でした
その中でも面白かったのが彼らから日本の地方都市に対する質問が多かったことです
例えばよし俺もしお前がこれから3日間休みだとしたが日本のどこに
有名な観光地は嫌なんだ
まだ世界の人が知らないそんな場所に行ってみたい
どこがいい聞いてくるわけです
私は面白くなってじゃあ例えば
長野県の蓼科行ってみませんかと
私は高校卒業してそこでおもてなしを学んで
日本文化を学びました面白いそこに行きたいな
言ってくれるわけです
そうすると私条約以下説明します
まずははこのホテルから東京まで私リってください
でそこから託し東京行き方ってしないけどでまぁ転写デー
そこから何番線のバスによって45分でそこから
とかって言ってるのですねあの不安そうなか本格を見て取れました
秦それなかなか行くの難しいだと
ちなみにそこにいる岡見は英語喋れるのか
そうか喋れないのか
そしたらまぁ今回は遠慮していこうかな
そんな話が終わることが多かったです
とても悔しかったです確かに今このお客さんが日本語しゃべらないお客さんがあの
ホテルに行けるか w いけないでしょう納得しました
でもすごくもったいないと思いました
この東京にいるホテルお客さん半分が外国人で一部が地方都市に目をむいている
重要があるわけですね
片一方地方の当てるでは
人口減少のもとにお客さんがどんどん減って
新しいマーケットが欲しかって欲しくてたまらない
もしこれがつながれば
両者ハッピーなるんじゃないか
そんな思いを持つようになりました
それが私がこの国際協約に来た理由でもあります
今ここにある国際協約山の中に約1戦にの学生が入って200人が外国人になると
もちろん観光業ではないですが
地方都市に海外の人がいるそんな状況に惹かれて私は校に入りました
秋田の観光炎上につい
戻ります
例えば
外国人が秋田のことについて調べるときやはりインターネットを使えます
どう仕上げるか今皆さんももしよかったらやってください
アルファベットで秋田と調べます何が出てくるかという話なんですね
a 出てくるのは開きたいのです
うん
もしかしたら今調べてくださった皆さんの中には秋田プリふぇくちゃーがちゃんと出て
きた方もいるかもしれません
でもそれはインターネットのテクノロジーのおかげです今3私たちは秋だけにいるので
秋田県が出てくるかもしれないんですが
それが県外国外で調べるとアルファベット j くるのはほとんど秋田院なんです
そうこの厚だという地域は世界には知られていないんです
地域活性化をやっていく上でこれの大きな問題になります
世界の人は秋田を知らない
秋田の人は世界がどうなっているか分からないんです
tan
今
地方創生と言われる言葉がこの地域を席巻しています
どうにかして地域を活性化させたいと地域の皆さん
by 頑張っていますでも実際の答えは分からないんですねどうやっていけばいいか
いろんな先生方が来て教えてくれますでも最初の一歩どうしたらいいのと秋田県
誰も知られていないよと
そんな中でどうやって世界に広めていくのか本当のところ分からないのが現状なんです
ana
私自身
観光が始めて4年いろいろ悩みながらやってきました
ん
そんな中で
実は一人の外国人のお客様が私たち地域に大きなヒントをくれた出来事がありました
その時のツアーは秋田県羽後町というところで実施したツアーです
秋だけ25市町村あるんですがそのう5月という地域でまさにこういう風景
農山村アヒル広がる
3そうですここの皆さんと一緒に
宴会5人を受け入れようと
農家さん張り切ってくれましたよしじゃあ
小町は西馬音内そばが有名だからそんなを作りをさせようと
外国人で
そうあの天ぷらが好きだしいいよとアジアの天ぷらも用意しようよと
いやそんなこと言ったらさ最近テレビで外国人が回転寿司のところ
両立できてるらしいよじゃ寿司も作るか
安氏はちょっと高いから餅つきに変えとこ
いろんなことを準備しました
そして実際にお客さんが来たんですね
たくさんのお客さんが来て地域の皆さんが教えて
楽しんでくれました
この光景を見た時に一人の農家のお母さんがちょっと不安になりました
若い皆さんがたくさん来て身長もみんな高いと
もしかしたら私たちが用意してご飯じゃ足りないんじゃないかと
せっかく海外からてくれ残高動画がいっぱいになってほしい
慌ててキッチンに戻ってみたら炊きたてのご飯がある
おにぎり作ろうに火を作り出したんですね
そうしていると
それを見た一人の3箇所が近寄っていきました
そしてすっごいこう興味津々で見てるんですね
i see 生
雑話柄を握りずジャイアン号
そういうんですよね私どういうことと思う
おにぎりは知ってるんだよね運営を握りっていうのは三角形なんだけど
何が面白いっ
そしたら彼女を続けるんですあいの aino 握り
愛犬バイおにぎりーコンビニエンスとは今如何10位
内部はちょっとにぎりー
tv メディアあーまんだ
場合下旬の
y おにぎりすちはやんご
なあ ion
まだマザーズ版でんいざちゃい暗号
はーいっかあれっそういうわけですねどういうことか
うかもちろん世界の人々を握り知ってるんです
確かに日本のコンビニエンスとは世界中にあります
そこで参加機能にいらっしゃるんですねテレビで萌え漫画でもおにぎり食べるシーンが
出てくるんでしょう
でも
なぜそれが三角結果というのは分からなかっ
それが見るとお母さんたちが握っているおにぎりがー
その形が参加型だとお母さんが握り姿を見てあ
だから参加型7
喜んでくれました
そしてじゃないんじゃない家はない
キャナ1 y と明記 this おにぎり彼女は言って農家さんのお母さんの中に
参加しました
れ実際作り出したのです
意外にこれ難しいんです
熱々のおにぎりを手に乗せるこれ初めての人じゃなかなかできません
そうするとお母さんがこう言ってじゃあさんの水をつけてやりなさいと
いうわけですねでもこれも難しい
たくさん水をつけすぎるとご飯がバラバラになって崩れてしまうんですね
みんな格ゲーって楽しんでくれました
お母さんも正直驚きました
私たちいっぱい用意したのに
これが楽しかったのっおにぎりだったの
最終的に出来上がったおにぎり
三角形かどうかは置いておきましょう
何綺麗なおにぎりが出来上がりました
このおにぎりのストーリー
実は地域にとって大きなインパクトを与えました
私たちは地域の人々が海外からお客さんが来るっていうのは海を越えて
わざわざ私たちの地域に来てくれるなんとかし一杯おもてなしないと寿司も何もあれも
これも全部用意しないと正月 l も良いものを作らないと思うわけですでも感動した
のはこのおにぎりだったんですね
そうかとこれでよかったんだ
私たちが海外の目線を始めて地域に取り入れた瞬間でした
外国人が地域に来るということ
それはどういうことかえっ
もちろん一義的にはん
海外の皆さんが異文化の目で
地域の価値に感動するこのために観光をやっています
ただ実はこれだけじゃないんですん
その外国人が感動する姿を見て地域の皆さんが自分達の価値に気付く
おにぎりに価値があると思っていた人ほとんどいなかった
それが海外の人の目を通すことで自分たちの価値を自覚することができる
ここに大きなポイントがあるわけです
外国人が地域にやってくるということ
ん
よれば
外国人が感動して
それを地域の人たちが
自分たちの勝それを自覚すると
こういった循環が実は地方創生の最初の一歩であり
必要なことだと思います
あれ以来この秋田県羽後町には私たち約1000人の外国人を入れるようになりました
少しずつですが受け入れ先が増えてい
外国人の数が増えてきました
そして今であればロマ子こんな光景が広がっています
これは宣言先月行った台湾のお客様が
ん
羽後町を訪れて小学校で交流している姿です
彼ら
私が行くと喜んでマート行ってきてあ
外国人連れてくる人だ
今日何人連れてきたの
ハローの人に這う-1う
サワディカップの人と聞いてくるわけです
毛嚢バリアでみんなが話しています
おそらく彼らにとってこの経験は
将来大きく影響すると思いますたぶんこの中から誰かが私が留学に行きたい言い出す
でしょう
この中から
私が日本に帰って家羽後町に帰ってきてその魅力を世界に発信する
言い出すでしょう
こんな光景私たちもっと作りたいと思っています
えっ
地域活性化
必要なことは何か方法がわからないどうしていいかわからない
私たちがおにぎりが学んだことはこれです地域の皆さんがまずその自分たちの地域を
愛してそれを自信を持ってた者に共有するこのことが重要だと思います
今
私も
外国人を切れてみようかなでもやっぱり不安だな
そんな農家さんが羽後町がたくさんいます
そんな時先輩の農家性行為ます気にしなくていい
そんな特別なほどしなくていいから
もし迷ったらねおにぎり出せばいいから
嬉しがるよそういうわけです
またたくさんの若い人たちが今この地域の課題を解決しようと地域に行ってきています
この中にもそういった方がたくさんいると思います
皆さんの立ち位置どんな人として地域と絡んでいますか
地域の人
その地域で生まれて地域を何とかしようと思うような人でしょうか
ぜひ
その地域もっと愛してくださいそして
自信を持って会社に伝えてください
逆に外で生まれて
地域に入って何か変えようとしている人ですか
まず最初にやるべきことは自分の感動を地域の人に伝えるべきです
それが地域の人たちの自信につながり新たな発信につながっていくと思います
一番重要なことは何かその外の人も中の人も本気で地域にコミットすることだと思い
ます
単に
外の人間が外からツンツンとアドバイスするようなコンサルタント必要はない
外の人間がわざわざ来地域に入ってそこでコミットするから意味があるんです
ぜひ一緒にこの地域で未来を作りましょう
そして誰のためにあるのかそれは先ほどの
羽後町の子供たちのように私達の次の世代
それをつくっていく
そんな人たちのために行動しましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]